hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that is always in the
spirit of giving hosted by me a guy
who's always got a hankering for cookies
and milk and today it's a Cavalcade of
Christmas Carnage as we pit loads of
beloved Christmas movies against one
another and let them duke it out for
holiday season Supremacy We Love
Actually all of these a Christmas
stories but which Carol will die hardest
and enjoy a Wonderful Life probably not
the one that took too long to get their
no good keister off my property I'm
gonna give you to the count of ten to
get your ugly yellow no good keister up
my property I compare Today's Show to a
carnival because it'll be fun and bright
and exciting you don't have to buy a
ticket and No One's Gonna Ralph on the
tilta world but like any good State Fair
we couldn't possibly include every
popular ride or in this case Christmas
film that's ever existed because I don't
have a hard-working Army of elves
catering to my every whip Santa he works
what one night out of 365 but we have
been delivering quality episodes of
verses all year round so now let's take
a look at some not all of the contenders
for the best Christmas movie of them all
It's a Wonderful Life Love Actually A
Christmas Story Tangerine Home Alone elf
Trading Places National Lampoon's
Christmas Vacation a Muppet Christmas
Carol and uh what's the one movie with
the guy and he's in a building uh Die
Hard that's right oh how about die hard
too it takes place the next Christmas
right on the East Coast I'm being told
we shouldn't but I'm counting it anyway
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
iconic moments round four Angels We Have
Heard On High and then we'll do a Wild
Card round that could feature anything
from grinches to scrooches to Santas bad
good or otherwise but really any movie
that you put on around this time of year
could be considered a Christmas movie
Little Women the apartment Gremlins I'm
being told in my ear those are actual
Christmas movies so um you can put on
Zilla movie and make it festive it's
gonna be a full house here on versus
with Santa's sax stuff full of syrupy
cinematic sweetness you know now
anything about it Gremlins could take
this whole thing if the rest of y'all
aren't careful so let's remember the
rules don't feed the host after midnight
and this is a competition but it's all
for fun every movie featured today is
already on Saint Nick's good list and he
checked it twice before he was off by
Tim Allen hey yo
you killed him did not and if you find
yourself getting in your feelings about
a movie that you feel is unjustly
ignored relax the way I do you take off
your shoes and socks and you make fists
with your toes fish with your toes
I know I know it sounds crazy trust me
I've been doing it for nine years Let's
Get It On
round one box office judging from all
the vids like this that we tend to do
around Christmas it's pretty evident
that these movies are really popular
with the masses so much so that the
actual holiday movie season is kind of
all year long Lethal Weapon and die hard
both Christmas movies and were released
before the summer movie season even got
into full swing so let's see whose box
office knows lights up the reddest and
that metaphor is getting away from me
hey Prancer that was a movie right it's
an underrated reindeer that Prancer keep
your eye on it we did adjust for
inflation to keep things fair for all
the movies over the many decades but it
does seem like the 80s and 90s were the
sweet spot for dominating the multiplex
with presents even A Christmas Story
which by all accounts was the little
cult classic that could forged its way
into an annual 24-hour marathon on the
Ted Turner cable channel of your choice
it did okay in theaters too 53 million
smackers way back in 1983. all right so
now we have a bar it's been set and now
it's been passed by Kermit Gonzo Piggy
and a very grumpy Michael K mean the
Muppet Christmas Carol took in 60
million dollars in 1992 eight bucks of
which was from this guy I can't remember
if tiny Mark made it into a movie house
in 1989 for Christmas vacation but a
bunch of you did 155 million dollars for
team Griswold and that's going to be a
tough number to beat uh Barefoot John
McLean just did it die hard made 181
million dollars in 1988 and both Die
Hard 2 and elf soared past 200 million
dollars each and I really just wanted to
include those two movies in the same
sentence hey they both end with crazy
Flights of Fancy
[Music]
Trading Places was a Smash Hit in 1983
cementing SNL star Eddie Murphy as a
legit box office attraction decades
before we'd actually be saying SNL
instead of Saturday Night Live you know
it's kind of unfair to call Murphy just
an SNL star that dude put an entire show
on his bag and in my opinion he's the
greatest cast member in program history
and even just in terms of Christmas
movies actors who rocketed to fame
thanks to SNL have done very well this
time of year Eddie's got Trading Places
Chevy has Christmas Vacation Farrell has
elf and Bill Murray has Scrooged which
humbugged over a hundred million dollars
for itself oh and Dana Carvey and John
Lovitz were both entrapped in Paradise
which did six million dollars total but
it still took place on Christmas Eve so
it's a Christmas movie big movies come
out around Christmas we all know this
including two of the hugest movies ever
Avatar in 2009 and Star Wars the Force
awakens in 2015 those two movies team up
for a box office total of approximately
a kajillion dollars and I have a funny
feeling we're going to see one of those
franchises back in theaters sooner
rather than later even actually maybe
right now but if we're looking at a film
that crushed during the holiday season
and fills us with the Christmas spirit
we're heading back to 1990. and if your
time traveling is a family please
remember to make sure all members are
accounted for before the Journey Begins
what else can we be forgetting
Kevin home alone was an absolute monster
at the dawn of the new decade decorating
the bank with 622 million reasons to be
joyful so it looks like home alone is
going to take the first point of the day
and wait a minute good God that's Jimmy
Stewart's music It's a Wonderful Life
has entered the chat and we adjust for
inflation and account for a film
released way back when there is far less
competition in theaters but actually
It's a Wonderful Life didn't even recoup
its budget back in 1946. it made like
three million bucks which is gonna buy
some angel wings but in round one the
point goes to Kevin McAllister and his
truly terrible parents have a
celebratory Pepsi Fuller your movie is
in Pole Position
mom
dad
where are you guys
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score Well Clarence I have a funny
feeling that a certain 1940s holiday
classic is gonna fare a wee bit better
this time around after all critics have
hearts too and this stage will be won by
which film warmed them the most and the
verified audiences as well even the
grinchiest of moviegoers can have their
heart size increased by that feel-good
flick that gets you right in the tear
ducts as a matter of fact how about we
kick things off with the Grinch in this
round well it's gonna set a standard
anyway neither Jim Carrey's nor Benedict
cumberbatch's Grinch outings made it to
Fresh on the Tomato Meter and I've also
been informed that neither neither nor
nor nor are actual words my bad we'll uh
clean up the grammar next season if we
get picked up I do live on 34th Street
where miracles happen and bars get set
higher the 1947 telling you that vintage
Fable is certified fresh at 96 damn I
see you Kris Kringle can anything else
in my sleigh compete with that uh both
Christmas stories can that would be a
Christmas story and rare exports A
Christmas Tale sharing time at 90 each
also repping the 90s is die hard at 94
and It's a Wonderful Life at 93 percent
I'm telling you there's a whole
generation of folks that are going to be
ticked off if it's a wonderful life
doesn't win something today gonna get a
lot of angry tweets or at least angry
letters and that wonderful life does
have another present waiting under its
tree an audience score that is 95 Die
Hard can also brag about being in the
90s on both metrics matching its Tomato
Meter with a 94 percent that's enough to
even get Hans Gruber into the holiday
spirit
oh oh
so it appears we have a battle between
nakatomi Plaza and a bridge for a point
in round two but we ain't done yet
Tangerine a wonderful tale that was
released in 2015 is 96 on the TM Clause
is 95 as is The Nightmare Before
Christmas and Little Women that'd be the
2019 version which crushes the 94
version which is way down at all right
it's still a great 93 but as we saw with
the Whoville gang the Tomato Meter
doesn't always warm the soul sometimes
it roasts a movie like a chest on an
open fire Love Actually is fresh barely
at 64 percent home alone is at 67 and
Christmas vacation is at a Bill and Ted
approved 69 dude even the Muppets who
everyone loves and Michael Kane who we
all adore could only muster 75 all right
two more fun ones Bad Santa is at 78
which I think is a win and Batman
Returns which is definitely a Christmas
movie is it 81 percent the highest of
either Michael Keaton's outings as the
Kate Crusader all right so let's do one
more sweep of the audience show of hands
the scissor guy yeah Edward Scissorhands
is it 91 the apartments at 93 and A
Christmas Story makes for a viable
Contender here with 88 to couple with
its 90 in the Tomato patch but as
happens this time of year we're hard at
work in Santa's shop on valuable
research all the time and it's a
wonderful life is now being threatened
with another Jimmy Stewart flick he was
billed as James Stewart alongside
Margaret Sullivan for 1940s the shop
around the corner it's a Christmas movie
about two store workers who are
constantly at odds with each other but
they're smitten with their respective
pen pals and lo and behold the pen pals
turn out to be each other it's like
you've got mail if America wasn't online
the shop around the corner is by my
count the highest rated Christmas movie
on the Tomato Meter at 99 and its
audience score is 91 all right so that's
worthy of being on the scoreboard but
Tangerine it's 96 and It's a Wonderful
Life is right there all three good
points what the hell it's Christmas I
can afford all these points because
Clark Griswold and I are both expecting
big Christmas bonuses right huh I'm
getting an IBC bath towel aren't I Sammy
Goldberg
Bethel
Lou Parker Cinema VHS home video
recorder Colonel Tom Parker
the bath towel round three iconic
moments so Tangerine home alone and the
Jimmy Stewart collection each have a
point so far but now the playing field
is wide open because this round is all
about the scenes sequences and
scintillating cinematic seconds that
elevate a film from like to love and
from oh yeah I think I remember seeing
that too of course I've seen that what
am I an animal every flick has a shot
here and just because a moment is Iconic
doesn't mean it can't also be
cringe-worthy yeah I'm looking at you
Andrew Lincoln how did you think that
scene was going to play out you make a
bunch of poster board proclaiming your
love for your best friend sweetheart
after filming their wedding in the most
creepy way imaginable come on man you
know what the penalty for mac and on
your BFF's girl at Christmas should be
suffering through dystopian future chock
full of Walking Dead people so I'd say
justice has been served and it is a
widely recalled moment from a movie full
of them it's a credit to Love Actually
that the scene in question plays as well
as it does I also love Hugh Grant
falling for a of his staff as much as it
pains the HR department and Rowan
Atkinson is the uppity store clerk Bill
Nye is a rock star Emma Thompson weeping
then putting on a brave face Love
Actually does have plenty of ammo oh and
it's also got Alan Rickman but if we're
talking about Sir Rickman I might have
another Christmas movie that could be
even more iconic welcome to the party
pal indeed
[Music]
Die Hard is widely considered the goat
in the realm of action movies because
the whole damn thing is quotable start
to finish you get Argyle the limo driver
giving way to Howie Janeiro to Hans
Gruber to Sergeant Al Powell to
Alexander good enough's Carl to Bill
clay and all the wireless shoeless John
McLean is doing memorable things like
sneaking around air ducts leaping across
elevator shafts and jumping off
exploding rooftops fun fact it never
gets old so director John mctiernan
um forgot to tell Alan Rickman that he
was suddenly going to drop him some
distance in that climactic sequence so
the look of surprise you see on Hans
gruber's face when he's dangling on the
side of the building that's a hundred
percent genuine as for the Rolex that
Ellis gives Holly probably a knockoff
but Johnny boy ain't the only
protagonist capable of dispensing some
Nair do Wells Kevin McAllister executed
an ambitious battle plan to a t the wet
Bandits are creeping around the suburbs
of Chicago but Kev is ready whether it's
a fake Christmas party or a few Angels
who've built these souls to keep the
baddies at Bay or you know a full-on of
salt stacked with icy steps scalding hot
doorknobs and well-timed paint cans
Macaulay Culkin he was undefeated on his
home turf
[Music]
but Home Alone can also hit you in the
fields like a Love Actually or It's a
Wonderful Life when Kevin's family
finally gets back to him on Christmas
morning that's approaching George Bailey
and family level feels Christmas
vacation has something in there for
every family member from Dad's struggle
with the lights to Mom struggle with Dad
and the kids who struggle with their
entire extended nuclear bomb of a flock
but Cousin Eddie is always welcome at my
place and it's a wonderful addition to
the film when Clark gets a brief respite
from debauchery to enjoy some childhood
cheer in the Attic trading places in L
for packed with big laughs and a nice
message as is tangerine and even the
night before but every year it seems A
Christmas Story Just Hits different
Ralphie in the bunny suit the Scott
Farkas Affair his insatiable desire for
a very specific BB gun come on and over
a decade before another kind of
Christmas movie Dumb and Dumber had a
hoot with a tongue stuck on a frosty
pole A Christmas Story made us feel it
way back in 1983 and every year since as
I wrote the this piece yeah I ride them
too be honest raise your hand if you
thought I could even read I took a break
to walk my little reindeer Molly the
Wonder Dog around the neighborhood and
we saw not one not two but multiple
windows adored with a very familiar leg
lamp yes that one don't believe in us we
can't see I'm busy yeah but what is that
it's a major reward A Christmas Story
has been ingrained in our hearts and
Minds thanks to a loyal following that
grows stronger every year it may not be
quite as sweet as its wonderful wife or
as iconic A Tale As A Christmas Carol
but maybe that's what makes it stand
apart it makes us feel like we're Clark
Griswold in the Attic reliving our own
childhood memories and for that it wins
round three and gets on the scoreboard
it's Home Alone one A Christmas Story
one tangerine one and Jimmy Stewart too
but really just one foreign
[Music]
Angels We Have Heard On High regardless
of whether we acknowledge it or not
music is a crucial piece of the puzzle
in every motion picture with sound in
history even before the talkies could
talk they had a jangly tune to keep us
invested and when it comes to Christmas
Stories the soundtracks and score
ratchet their game up to accentuate a
laugh tug on a heartstring or celebrate
a fresh crop of dead terrorists imagine
Die Hard without Von Monroe's let it
snow at the end or Love Actually without
that kid on the drums and what would
Home Alone be without the
yes those tender notes strike a chord
that make a good movie great and turn a
memorable Christmas Tale into an
unforgettable one uh I'm I'm here with
my dad and we never met and he wants me
to sing him a song I'll kick off the
proceedings with everyone's favorite
talking mutant animals The Muppets The
feels like Christmas tune finally starts
to thaw the icy heart of Ebenezer
Scrooge and everyone watching at home
jingle bells or a staple at this time of
year as in jingle all the way or they
can accentuate a sequence in trading
places and even hit home with the
Christmas story there's even a classic
movie called White Christmas and guess
what ballad you'll find in that one
although that was actually originally
from Holiday Inn Tangerine had to
finagle a humble tune when the limited
budget prohibited a more well-known
Christmas rendition so Toyland it was
from Babes in Toyland It's a Wonderful
Life etched Hark the Herald Angels Sing
into our holiday fabric even more and of
course it's not a vacation movie until
we get a music packed opening credits
sequence Bonanza but for me this comes
down to a trio of movies that may not
seem linked on the surface a family
classic Like Home Alone a rom-com Like
Love Actually and the action icon Die
Hard Die Hard might feature as wide a
swath as any Christmas movie ever when
it comes to genre early in the film we
get an ominous score that leads into run
dmc's Christmas in Hollis but there's
also a recurring holiday feel in the
theme and then of course Q Vaughn for
the big closing number Home Alone phone
can go up Tempo with Rocking around the
Christmas tree or Run Run Rudolph but
can also go slow and sappy with a local
kids choir sounding like freaking angels
and that scene in the church right
before the wet Bandits are ambushed
shows us that even the weird old guy
living next door might be a good egg
after all Love Actually is practically
bookended by music that isn't just
adding on to a scene it's the focal
point of the action we meet Bill nye's
aging rock legend Billy Mack just as
he's crooning out another take of
Christmases all around and the familiar
song makes us feel it in our fingers and
our toes it's a funny oddly endearing
way to get us into this film and then we
have that climactic number hey kids you
want a cute guy to notice you pick up an
instrument or better yet sit down behind
a kit and start Keith mooning your way
into some fetching Young lass's Heart
let me try to recap the scene as
efficiently as possible Sammy is the
stepson of Daniel played by Liam Neeson
as they navigate through tragedy Sammy
decides to learn the drums to get the
attention of a classmate he's spent with
named Joanna who he then sneaks through
airport security to get a smooch before
she flies back to Amer America oh what a
movie Olivia Olson who plays Joanna
apparently sung All I Want for Christmas
so well that director Richard Curtis had
to coach her down to make it more
believable for a 10 year old it's a good
story and regardless of how you feel
about the mishmash plot the musical
numbers make you feel warm and cozy at
the season of giving Love Actually
there's some creepiness to you but it's
on the board and it all comes down to
this the Wild Card round Ghost of
Christmas present this round begins with
a simple question to all of you what's
your favorite Christmas movie could be
anything but here we're searching for
that movie that gives you the most
holiday bang for your buck and by the
way the movie called The Holiday ain't
too shabby of a lead off hitter it's got
comedy romance movie trailers A Little
Bit Of Heartache and it all ends up okay
by New Year's Eve love actually has that
too but in a much more haphazard style
than the smoother 2 protagonist journey
of the holiday tangerines similarly can
be funny and sweet as can the night
before and sure even off his Christmas
party if we're looking at kid friendly
Fair the adults can also enjoy though
I'd say Gremlins but that 1984 release
inadvertently teamed up with Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom to bring the
PG-13 rating into existence apparently
ripping hearts out of Chess and
microwaving Little Green Goblins was too
much for Tykes 12 and under but I have a
feeling we all saw those movies before
we were officially teenagers anyway
decades Before It's a Wonderful Life
White Christmas and holiday and all made
an impact even if it took George
Bailey's film years and even a
generation before earning its rightful
place amongst the Christmas classics as
the title of this round applies A
Christmas Carol is always in contention
so what's the best iteration my family
tends to go the dramatic route with the
George C Scott version but we also
dabble with the comedic hijinks of
Scrooged and you can't ever go wrong
with The Muppets and Michael Caine but
shout out also to Aleister Sim and
Albert Finney the fun shifts into
another gear when it's a family movie
that pushes the envelope for what the
kids can get away with enter A Christmas
Story which seems Ralphie getting in
fights and yearning for a Red Rider BB
gun or Home Alone where we get to see
Kevin McAllister without every kid's
dream we do want to be left home alone
we think and jumping on the bed and
ordering a bunch of pizza from Little
neroes is exactly what any of us would
have done at age eight or now I'm
probably gonna do that this weekend that
movie was such a milestone that kids
went from making forts in the woods to
booby trapping their own houses yeah we
did so to ward off criminals and maybe
we forgot to warn the adults that
actually lived there in the process but
then we arrived at the chimney of Die
Hard it seems the debate has died down
over whether it's a Christmas movie or
not either from fatigue or because it's
so overwhelmingly obvious that it's not
just a Christmas movie it's the
Christmas movie we even get a little
Santa reference in there and because
this Clause is really a dead terrorist
that makes more milk and cookies for the
rest of us Gremlins is about as far down
the horror genre as I care to go this
time of year and for everything else we
have Die Hard John McLean gives us
plenty of light-hearted moments thanks
to his one-liners the action is is among
the best ever to be put on Celluloid and
if you like an estranged couple getting
back together just in time for the
holidays die hard has that too plus the
sequel has John Frick and Amos and Fred
effing Thompson so the Christmas just
keeps getting more miraculous with
apologies to the Griswolds and the
mcallisters and the Muppets I'm going
with die hard as The Ultimate Christmas
film don't believe me just ask my Advent
calendar which is nakatomi Plaza I get
to eat a chocolate out of each four
until I get all the way up to the 30s
yippie Kaye indeed do you really think
you have a chance against us Mr cowboy
so Die Hard wins the Wild Card round
meaning Love Actually Home Alone
Tangerine the Jimmy Stewart 1940s era
and John McCain's Greatest Hits are all
tied up so how do I determine one giant
winner of the show today will it see
Jimmy Stewart has both the shop around
the corner and it's a wonderful life so
that's enough presence under his tree
Tangerine is a small film that got a
good run today some more eyeballs will
be on it Merry Christmas home alone is
basically the kid version of Die Hard by
the way who wins in a fight between
Kevin and John any what do you want to
bet and I think that leaves us with a
Christmas story it feels the most like a
real family the kids can be mischievous
like in Home Alone the adults have real
problems like in Die Hard and the story
feels much more relatable than the most
Fantastical flights of holiday Whimsy
and we might learn a little something
about the real meaning of Christmas in
the process but home alone has John
Candy and Home Alone 2 has Tim Curry you
know what it's too late A Christmas
Story is the winner of today's Christmas
cavalcade unless we're also counting
Christmas specials in which case
Garfield's Christmas is the clear Victor
dad would chop down the tree anybody no
Merry Christmas
well that's gonna put a bow on this
episode of versus but if any of you out
there think I just went with my favorite
childhood holiday movie you'd be wrong I
never even saw a Christmas story until
after I'd moved to LA and I met Peter
Billingsley as an adult at The Comedy
Store I was late to the party but the
shindig gets stronger every year so hit
me up on social media at Mark Ellis live
with your favorite Christmas suggestions
and keep it right here at Rotten
Tomatoes for all the latest and greatest
in the world of wonderful wintry
entertainment thanks for watching versus
I'm Mark Ellis this is Godzilla and the
quarterback is toast